pourquoi vous vivez vous ce qui se passe
dans le pays
françois mitterrand
44%
[Applaudissements]
sur le fond
arlette laguiller 560
1280 2,30 % des voix rené dumont qui lui
aussi dépasse les 300 milles 305 1448
soit 1,30 pour cent des voix
je vous remercie
[Musique]
ils se sont bien débrouillés un ces
candidats ils ont été heureux ils ont
fait plaisir à leurs familles à leurs
petits clans politiques mais il faut ils
vont être 40 la prochaine fois et je
crois que là à ce moment là ce sera
quelque chose d'absolument ahurissant
pour le jeu sera pour tout de suite
la campagne électorale a été pour nous
l'occasion de sortir du néant de nous
faire connaître et connaître des
positions dans le tronc que les français
ne connaissais pas qui sont celles de la
droite sociale populaire et nation
[Musique]
on
la sous préfecture de l'eure et loire
vient en effet de connaître une élection
historique entre guillemets puisque pour
la première fois depuis la guerre une
grande ville de france est cogérée par
un parti d'extrême droite
le bruit et la fureur c'était hier soir
au moment de l'annoncé des résultats
puis plus tard dans la nuit ou les crs
sont intervenus le rétablir dans la rue
un ordre troublé par les partisans une
certaine idée de la démocratie
et les vainqueurs de ce scrutin
municipal
[Musique]
ce qui fait ma force je crois c'est que
j'apparais aujourd'hui à dreux en tout
cas
celui qui dit tout haut ce que la
majorité des droits pour tous
la trinité-sur-mer compte aujourd'hui
deux personnalités eric tabarly et jean
marie le pen qui a obtenu hier soir 51%
des voix de la commune c'est un
événement
et
en dépassant le seuil des 10% l'extrême
droite en france et pour la première
fois pour la première fois de sortie de
sa position marginalisés
[Musique]
nous reste maintenant à donner à notre
mouvement
les bars et l'organisation qui lui
permettront
dans les échéances décisives
de rassembler autour de son programme de
renaissance nationale
la majorité des français
la classe politique est paniqué ses
membres
ses membres au pays que la marée du
front national ne cesse de monter de la
digue est fissurée qu'elle a cédé à
vitrolles et qu'elle va maintenant se
disloquer ils ont compris que leur temps
est fini et il s'affole
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
l'essai violence et l'insécurité a
fonctionné à plein et jean marie le pen
l'a utilisé comme levier
il est clair la stratégie du front
national depuis 1978 à partir du moment
où il a décidé de passer à hautem de
lentilles migration avant il ne l'avait
pas ça a été toujours de faire légitimer
ses positions par les partis de droite
voire de gauche parfois pour pouvoir
ensuite dire nous ne sommes pas des
extrémistes
au contraire vous avalisez une partie de
nos propositions nous nous proposons le
tout on a vu avec le débat sur
l'identité nationale avec la question
des roms avec l' usage de thèmes plus ou
moins islamophobe dans le débat public
les positions du front national être
avalisées et celui ci progresser
logiquement c'est ce qui se passe depuis
[Musique]